nous rejoignons maintenant direct à
ajaccio benoît duquesne benoît l'enquète
on l'a dit progresse actuellement trois
personnes sont placées en garde à vue et
leur signalement correspondrait au type
maghrébin
absolument et 6,7 cette piste se se
vérifier bien il faudrait expliquer
comment des nationalistes corses peuvent
être amenés à faire appel pour lutter
contre dans leur lutte contre la france
à faire appel à des hommes ou des jeunes
hommes donné société marocaine alors
d'après les spécialistes de la lutte
antiterroriste et bien ça ne serait pas
tout à fait une surprise en tout cas pas
une première puisque dans d'autres faits
mineurs cela rend tout cas moins graves
eh bien on a déjà vu des petits malfrats
de banlieue quelquefois d'origine
étrangère enrôlé comme ça par des
nationalistes pour poser une bombe ici
ou là notamment dans le sud de la france
mais si ce n'est pas forcément une
surprise en tout cas ce serait quand
même le signe d'une certaine
déliquescence de ce mouvement vous
pourrez dire qu'il s'agit d'une sorte de
mercenaire utilisé par des organisations
clandestines dissidente
alors c'est un petit peu toute la
question c'est là dessus qu'on beaucoup
insisté monsieur jospin et monsieur
chevènement savoir qui manipule
éventuellement qui commandite qui a pu
armer les bras de ses jeunes si encore
une fois ce sont eux ce qui n'est pas
approuvée pour l'instant pour réfuter
quand même l'un des actes les plus des
terroristes les plus importants qu'il
puisse exister assassiné un préfet de la
république alors dans un premier temps
par on pense bien sûr au flnc canal
historique pourquoi il vient pour toutes
sortes de raisons d'abord parce que ils
ont mis frein à la trêve qu'ils avaient
eux mêmes décidé au lendemain de
l'arrivée des socialistes au pouvoir
ensuite parce que la personnalité du
préfet claude erignac en tout cas son
arrivée pouvait pour eux être synonyme
de
le changement de politique de monsieur
juppé quand il avait décidé de laisser
tomber certaines négociations
clandestine au profit des arrestations à
commencer par celle de françois santoni
qui était l'un des deux rôles de leur
leader et puis il ya la proximité des
élections régionales ou territoriales
comme on dit ici et là on peut imaginer
qu'un mouvement comme celui-là est en
vie de réapparaître brutalement sur la
scène politique alors qu'il est en perte
de vitesse mais tout cela n'est pas
aussi simple d'abord parce que la
plupart des mouvements nationalistes ce
soir condamne cet attentat et puis
ensuite parce que cette mouvance se
déchirent de mois en mois de plus en
plus en de multiples groupuscule
et qu'il est très difficile de les
contrôler et bien évidemment de savoir
ce qu'ils font et que cela permet toutes
les surenchères merci benoît duquesne